welcome to this video playing sat OS
poom something like that from Brazil
let's see the way then we have an RDD 3i
gives me the bishop I'm happy to take it
should have gone I should have gone c 3
first okay out definitely want to I can
I can hear I can also block it and go
with night h5 or some other night move
too young maybe maybe just do that and
then play for a five ultimately what is
it doing playing it against the a six
spot which is protected by the bishop
okay hmm advanced or advancing or not
advancing not interesting interesting
decision therefore is very closed ein
very close position not sure that black
can break through them here maybe play
some strengthening move first and also
the question is what about the night jam
oh he's giving up the idea to play
Knight to f3 so I'm glad to bring the
night to deform he's really keen on
doubling against the ultra protected for
Nia that's really funny ok after f4 he
can never challenged the d4 night and he
cannot go to d5
now the knight on d4 is also always
keeping one one piece of white for the
defense of of p3 so it's really a really
nice ok I want to make sure that nothing
happening them Bishop cagr I can go here
actually that that's good that's a good
way to put it maybe also here I don't
know I can also just take it maybe can
play G for it maybe play G for now
that's true
I maybe can play g4 already as black
here but I want the a a rock into into
the game yeah h4 and taking on age 3 or
is this is there something better there
c'mon let's do that don't want to and i
can i'm not going to take him it's
really really no problem look we can
also get the Queen tell form it's not
bad
yeah I'm not so sure how to play it
maybe you first get get this thing on
the queenside taken care of like a form
is Knight to g5 then maybe maybe 96 to
f4 but then Queen g4
okay still slightly tricky don't see a
direct way to win yet knight on d5 is
Sam this is a problem
hmm
maybe maybe he ran the tag f3 give up 85
okay and so time warning how do I win
this night to night back to e7 so that i
can double maybe
hmm
yeah it can be tricky with the time but
ultimately ultimately this is winning
this position
Knight to f4 me check check
yeah you cannot win this so and really
really screw this up get the King may be
over
check check check
check check check mate with two seconds
on the clock yeah and probably not
really a deserved win I really screwed
this up completely from this from this
winning position yeah maybe I should
have returned they exchange quickly or
something it's really not so easy to
play against this this is this knight on
d5 there were some ways to return the
exchange not very hard I don't know
maybe maybe I'm just blind or something
but i found this was tricky to claim
okay here here look g7 and roop to f7
maybe yeah this seems to be a clear win
according to the computer minus form now
I place look the second what's the
purpose of property 7 nobody knows
and now the computer wants to play night
at five which does not make any sense to
me at least why exactly what you want to
do that Mike why can you not shuffle I
mean who is some okay one and then it's
it's hanging of course so probably I can
combine the threats against f3 with this
a for idea yeah there should be a win
somewhere but I have 30 seconds so glad
to have managed at all in the end okay
thanks for watching